[Musique]
ok ok notre invité politique ce matin
c'est François patria bonjour merci
d'être avec nous sénateur de la Côte
d'Or président du groupe RDPI c'est le
groupe des sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par Christ Bertrand du groupe
La Dépêche bonjour Christ bonjouran
bonjour François bonjour François patria
on va commencer en parlant du projet de
loi immigration qui a donc été voté hier
par les sénateurs voté mais durci par la
majorité de la droite et du centre et
pourtant vous l'avez voté ce projet de
loi ça veut dire que la version vous
convient pas du tout été très clair
j'aiété très clair sur le sujet de dire
en quoi notre vote était positif pour ce
qui concerne l'avenir du texte mais en
quoi nous n'étions en aucun cas en
mesure de donner quitus à la majorité du
Sénat du texte tel qu'elle l'a présenté
ça veut dire quoi concrètement nous
sommes d'accord avec le fait que le
gouvernement a raison aujourd'hui de
déposer un texte de loi immigration qui
permettra à la fois de mieux renvoyer
ceux qui doivent partir et de mieux
accueillir ceux qui doivent venir et de
faire un texte qui est équilibré en la
matière en second lieu nous pensons que
dans le texte il y a eu des votes qui
nous ne conviennent pas du tout à titre
d'exemple je me suis exprimé dans
l'hémicycle nous avons voté pour un
amendement visant à rétablir l'ame que
le Sénat a transformé en nous avons voté
clairement pour cet amendement nous
avons été battu nous avons voté aussi
contre l'amendement de l'écriture tel
qu'elle est de l'article 4 bis nous
avons voté nous avons
aussi soutenu aujourd'hui le
rapprochement familial nous avons sur
nous avons ajouté et par contre et en
plus nous avons obtenu gain de cause sur
nos 17 amendements 11 ont été adoptés il
y a eu sur l'article 1 sur l'article 8
sur l'article 9 sur l'article 12 des
rétablissements important que nous avons
voté donc dans ce texte il y a des
éléments irritants même plus que nous
n'acceptons pas dans le même temps dans
le même temps il y a un texte qui ne
fait pas seulement deux articles sur
lesquels il y a eu polémique mais qui a
plus de 90 articles dans lequel
globalement ce texte sert de base ce que
nous voulons c'est que le texte
aboutisse le texte aboutisse parce que
la France en a besoin le pays en a
besoin pour aboutir il faut évidemment
donner quelques gages et faire en sorte
qu'arriver à l'Assemblée parce que le
troisième point c'est ce que nous
comptons et ce qui se passera dans le
texte infin l'ame sera rétablie
l'article 3 sera réécrit
ou voterex et onver pas d'accord cm
alors je vais vous répondre madame que
sur sur les lignes
rouges président du groupe républicain
avait dit que s'il y avait le moindre
aspect dans un texte d'accroche qui
permettait de donner des titres de 6
jour à des travailleurs en situation
régulière il ne le voterait jamais il l'
voté dans l'article 4 bis est bien prévu
qu'il a une possibilité certes durci
mais elle existe et il avait dit s'il a
la moindre possibilité je ne le voterai
pas donc je pense que ceux qui ont
reculé en l'occurence sous la pression
des centristes on voter c'est que C et
donc c'est une des raisons aussi
supplémentaires laissez-moi finir je P
tout à fait sous la pression des
centristes je pense qu'il y a eu une
révision et que nous avons aussi voté ce
texte parce que justement il y a dans
l'article 4 qui est pas si mal écrit que
ça il est durci par exemple sur lacord
de l'employeur ça c'est pas possible
aujourd'hui il est durci et bien il dans
ce texte article 4 bis l'accroche que
nous souhaitons pour que ce que nous
souhaitons voir c'est que l'article 4
bis soit réécrit dans le sens où il
était à l'origine et vous le verrez
qu'il sera à la Faculté vous dites Bruno
rotillot a fait marche arrière sur
l'article 3 ou l'article 4 B en
acceptant le 4 bis il fera marche
arrière sur la me bien entendu il fera
je pense que ce que je crois ce que je
crois non je dis non mais sinon il y
aura pas texte c'est
clairire la majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale ne laissera jamais passer un
texte sans il aura peut-être pas il y
aura peut-être pas d'accord en CMP mais
il y aura après une lecture ici au Sénat
et à l'Assemblée mais il y aura un texte
final dans lequel il y aura laame le
ministre y tient le la première ministre
y tient et l'ensemble de la majorité y
tient et ça me paraît aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs quand j'ai dis cela vous
savez j'ai un pldoyer pour la me en
disant que supprimer la me c'était une
faute éthique une faute sanitaire une
faute économique voilà c'est clair on n
pas très bien compris juste sur
l'article 3 parce que vous nous dites
l'article 4 bis finalement tel que
réécrit par le Sénat ça convient mais
vous souhaitez que l'assemblée revienne
à non qu'elle qu'elle va réécrire
l'article 4 bis qui sera un article 3
voilà que faut pas voilà mais qui
reviendra pas à ce qu'il était à
l'origine vous garderez les modification
du scénat vous souhaitez en tout cas que
les modifications du Sénat soit Gard pas
du tout pas du tout je souhaite non je
mais si ça vous va que la manière dont
il a été ré ah non j'ai dit qu'il était
pas mal écrit j'ai dit qu'il était
surtout acceptable en l'état puisquil y
avait dedans des choses qu'on ne peut
pas accepter notamment l'accord de
l'employeur pour le faire je vous l' dis
comme tel voilà donc cet article 4 bis
sera écrit ce sera un autre article 3 et
nous comptons sur l'Assemblée nationale
pour le faire mais dans le même temps en
en marquant notre accord sur non pas sur
les éléments que j'ai dit mais c'est V
dire c'est un vote d'espoir si je peux
dire par là que ce texte puisse aboutir
alors si l'article 3 est rétabli que
laame est rétabli comment espérez-vous
avoir le vote d'une partie DLR de
l'assemblée qui est nécessaire pour
éviter un 493 ce qu'il est possible
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée je fais pas de
moi je fais pas de prévision comme cela
mais j'essaie de regarder ce qu' est
possible à l'Assemblée j'entends bien ce
qu'a dit monsieur vqué hier au
parlementaires j'entends ce que disent
les ténors de de le parti eux-même et
puis qui s'expriment on parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure de ce que dit
Monsieur sioti pour ou on par on parlera
mais je vois bien que il y a une forme
d'incohérence chez eux vous avez compris
que chez les républicain il y a trois
courants à l'Assemblée nationale ceux
qui sont contre ceux qui s'abstiennent
ceux qui sont pour être pour
éventuellement il y a une profonde
division mais je ce que je pense ce que
je espère le gouvernement en tout cas le
ministre c'est qu'à l'Assemblée je pense
que le groupe lot lot va pouvoir voter
avec nous ils auront un corrapporteur ce
qui fait 21 voix supplémentaires il
suffit qu'il y ait après une vingtaine
ou 25 voix de de la d'abstention des
républicains sur 60 et passenir est-ce
qu'ils peuv s'abstenir sur un texte qui
verrait le rétablissement de l'article 3
et de
laame je pense qu'il y en a une partie
qui peuvent qui peuvent je pense je
pense aujourd'hui ATER sur 25 je pense
écoutez il faut pas en plus faut pas
faire de de pronostic comme ça parce que
il peut y avoir d'autres scénarios il
peut y avoir un blocage de la part de
l'opposition il peut y avoir un
embouteillage il peut y avoir les tas de
choses donc mais mais vous le craignez
est-ce que vous craignez qu'il y a
certains groupes d'opposition a a priori
de la gauche qui fassent obstruction et
qui empêche l'avancée de ce débat à
l'Assemblée nationale bien entendu
j'attends je m'attends au pire avec avec
LFI qu' fasse tout pour en fin de compte
alors qu'il s'agit d'accueillir mieux
les gens de faire tous quand le blocage
quand le blocage quand le blocage c'est
l'attitude systématique sur tous les
textes aujourd'hui ils ont montré
jusqu'à présent et c'est pourquoi dans
l'opinion maintenant ils sont
discrédités mais vous craignez qu' la
fille fasse obstruction pour vous
pousser au 4 93 c'est ça vous P vous
êtes inquiet de ça ce que je vous dis
c'est c'est que l'objectif du
gouvernement je comprendre que la
première ministre et le ministre ne sont
pas favorables à un 493 on fera tout
pour éviter un 493 après je sais pas
comment se déroulera le scénario je suis
bien incapable de vous donner dérouler
la gauche va ne va pas voter va voter
contre ce texte la majeure partie des
républicains va voter contre ou
s'abstenir ce texte finalement va
reposer sur le vote du groupe du
Rassemblement nationale à l'Assemblée
est-ce que c'est pas un problème pour la
majorité non dans le scénario que je
vous ai évoqué j'ai pas évoqué ça je
vous ai dit la majorité plus le groupe
lot plus abstention républicain j'ai pas
parlé du rassemblement national
maintenant si le rassemblementtiontion
non mais si le rassemblement national si
le rassembl nationale décide de
s'abstenir parce qu'il pense que dedans
il y a des mesures et qu' reconnaît
qu'il y a des mesures efficaces pour le
faire son problème c'est pas enfin là
recherche aujourdhui c'est par
aujourd'hui dit c'est une petite loi et
dimanche dans le JDD dit que même
réécrit par le Sénat ça lui va pas donc
c'est la réponse à votre questione je
rappelle quand même ça pendant ce texte
que notre vote hier que les choses
soient bien claires je beaucoup ça n'est
en aucun cas inquitud tenz à la majorité
sénatoriale l'interview de Sacha Houlier
la semaine dernière en plein examen du
texte au Sénat qui donne une interview
au Figaro disant que de toute façon
l'assemblée rétablira le texte initial
et qu'a le dernier mot est-ce que c'est
vraiment
ortant je pense en l'occurrence oui
c'est important pas c'est pas un manque
de respect pour le Sénat qui est en
train de travailler sur le texte écoutez
non seulement c'est pas manque de
respect mais je vous rappelle que le
gouvernement a pour la première fois mis
un texte régalien en première lecture
devant le Sénat avant l'assemblée et
après tout c'est pas c'est pas que que
la c'est la c'est la Constitution qui
dit que l'Assemblée nationale le dernier
mot mais c'est le gouvernement mais
estce que la deou c'estou non mais il a
voulu marquer par là le fait que
effectivement le Sénat était en train de
durcir la loi et de la dénaturé
effectivement mais que justement la
majorité était là pour rétablir le texte
tel que le souhaite le gouvernement et
la majorité présidentielle aujourd'hui à
l'état ça ça traduit quoi ça traduit pas
aussi un peu de fébrilité de la part de
sachalier non mais je pense ça chouier
est un président de de commission
compétent qui l'écoute que le rapporteur
qu'ils ont fait nommer est un rapporteur
qui aujourd'hui a déjà pris beaucoup de
contact qui travaille mais il y a pas de
division dans la majorité tout le monde
est derrière la vie de sachaoulier ou il
y en a qui sont plus enclins au
compromis que lui il vous a pas échappé
que dans dans tous les partis compris
dans la Renaissance aujourd'hui il y a
des gens qui viennent de la gauche des
gens qui viennent de la droite des gens
qui je pense un peu différemment je leur
dis surtout de mettre sous les teignoirs
l'attitude qui conduit à la fronde parce
qu'on a vu ce que ça a donné sur le
dernier quinena dernier c'est
l'avant-dernier quinena pardon celuià
donc je pense que effectivement il y a
des sensibilités qui s'exerce après tout
c'est normal moi je ma sensibilité je
sais d'où elle vient et ma position sur
la me elle parce que je viens de la
gauche aujourd'hui mais il y a dans mon
groupe aujourd'hui des des sénateurs qui
viennent de la droite qui avaient une
sensibilité différente c'est pas pour ça
qu'on s'est divisé sur le vote on à la
gauche de votre MAJ de pas devenir des
frondeurs c'est ça le message voà ok
tout à fait on va parler des rencontres
de sint oui après manuel bonpard et
Olivier force éc Coti qui a annoncé hier
qu'il ne se rendrait pas aux prochaines
rencontrre de Saint-Denis vendredi
est-ce que c'est la fin de l'initiative
lancée par le Président de la République
non mais d'abord attendez c'est
l'attitude d'éic fotti quand on est
digne et responsable on répond à
l'invitation du chef de l'État quand on
est digne et responsable lui dit on va
on met ses actes en cohérence avec ses
propositions
quand on est digne et responsable on
n'installe pas le RN comme ils veut le
faire aujourd'hui je m'explique les
républicains ont souhaité qu'il y ait un
référendum autour de la Constitution et
autour le président le met sur la table
met sur la table voilà je le mets sur la
table on pourra en discuter et Monsieur
siti qui l'a demandé qui dépose une PPL
sur le
sujet qui dépose sur le texte loi dit S
fait pas parce qu'il était pas la manif
non mais vous rendez compte cette
réaction que ça veut dire qu'il faut
cesser de Tom la main il est plus
totalement mais je trouve que c'est une
démission et en plus je trouve que c'est
c'est c'est dramatique pour les
républicains de même même chose pour les
socialistes hein qui sont en train alors
qu'ils ont déjà été je veux dire
ébranlés par les élections qui qui se
sont passées pendant les 6 années
maintenant continue continue continue à
baisser leur assise local parce que
c'est pas compris par les Français qu'un
président qu'un chef de parti
aujourd'hui à l'invitation du président
pour sujet parler de sujet comme la
Constitution comme le référendum comme
l'évolution aujourd'hui disent non il
était pas la manif je viens pasz c'est
voilà c'est clair clairement le
président tendait la main au LR avec
cette proposition de référendum qui
aurait pu intégrer des sujets comme
l'immigration est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'il faut cesser de tendre la main au
LR que de toute manière ça ne sert à
rien c'est pas l'attitude du président
cro que le président est terriblement
démocrate en l'occurrence qu' le fait il
montre tous les jours qu'il recherche
l'Union dans ce pays que contrairement à
ce qu'on dit ne divise pas mais
recherche l'Union l'initiative qu'il a
pris à Saint-Denis et qui a déjà
débouché sur quatre mesures positives
dans la conférence sociale donc c'est
pas pas des récontres inutiles c'est pas
le machin dont on parle c'est c'est une
c'est une réunion à Saint qui a débouché
sur des sur des réformes sur fait sur
des actions concrètes là il s'agit de
d'anticiper ce que pourêtre demain la
réforme tout le monde demande des
référendum aujourd'hui moi je ne suis
pas de cela he c'est so soit clair je
pense qu'il faut être très prudent avec
le référendum et ne pas toucher tout le
temps la Constitution mais il y a une
demande populaireh
présidu non moi j'ai dis j'ai dit mon
avis c'est je donne mon avis président
de la République aujourd'hui a dit qu'
qu' pouvait le faire qui pouvait le
faire on peut faire ça dépend dans
quellees conditions moi je donne mon
avis je suis très je pense que la
Constitution l'a touché c'est c'est
toujours très délicat
elle a ses preuvve votre avis c'est
qu'il faut pas élargir le champ du
référendum je dis ça ça dépend sur
l'immigration bah écoutez ce seront aux
chefs de parti de décider mais là sans
par exemple sur les seuils je pense que
les seuils je crois que le Sénat il
réfléchit ici les seuils sont trop bas
aujourd'hui ils étaient trop ha avec
4lion 5 1 million c'est trop bas se pour
rérend pour le RIB tout à fait donc le
président va enfin justement
l'opposition le demande la gauche le
demande la droite le demande les
républicains le demande dépose un texte
de loi sur le sujet le président dit
d'accordons nous on vient pas je pense
qu'il y a une forme d'irresponsabilité
d'indignité de purité puisquefi le PS et
lesr ne viennent pas à cette réunion
sur gens qui serontz aa mon r il y aura
les
ver g ve dire qu'on peut avancer même
sans un consensus total sur cette
question là président il va écouter il
va écouter leur proposition il va les
lire va leur répondre ben on avance avec
ceux qui veulent avancer on avance on
avance pas avec ceux qui fuit qui fuit
le combat voilà un mot juste après on va
parler de la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme mais vous disiez le 12
décembre prochain le Sénat va examiner
la la proposition de pardon
constitutionnel DLR pour élargir le
champ du référendum et permettre un
référendum sur l'immigration donc ce que
souhaite le chef de l'État est-ce que du
coup vous votrez texte je d'abord je je
l'ai vu aujourd'hui je pense que ce
texte ne passera pas parce qu'il y a
autre chose dans le texte il y a
d'autres choses il y a les compétences
il y a les des accords européens dedans
et je
suis je pense aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a
pas de majorité au Sénat pour la voter
ah même au Sénat je pense vous pensez
que les pas aujourd'ui je vois pas
aujourd'hui les centristes voter texte
dans mais vous vous le voterez pas mais
moi non pour l'ANT on parle de vous le
disiez tout à l'heure Éric sooti invoqué
l'absence du président de la République
à la manifestation dimanche dernier
contre l'antisémitisme pour justifier
son absence à saintis vendredi prochain
est-ce que c'était une faute de la part
du président de la République de ne pas
assister à cette marche auquel ont
assisté la président enfin l'initiative
d'ailleurs du président du Sénat et de
la président de l'assembblé à chaque
fois que le président prend une décision
ça donne lieu à débat discussion à
controverse c'est pasendez moi j'étais
de ceux j'étais de ceux qui pensait que
le président ne devait pas y aller
pourquoi pour quelle raison d'abord
parce que le contexte le contexte le
contexte bien entendu original c'est la
lutte contre les actes antisémitises
antisémit dans notre pays bon donc là le
président éta très clair il s'est
exprimé à trois reprises dans la semaine
pour dire qu'il condamnait toute forme
d'antisémitisme de haine et de
xénophobie il l'a dit il l'a écrit les
choses sont claires en second lieu cette
semaine et ça nuit un petit peu la
manifestation je le dis comme telle
parce que elle a donné lieu à beaucoup
de polémiques stériles et inutiles sur
savoir qui viendrait qui viendrait ou
qui viendrait pas on ça a tourné autour
de cela je suis sûr que ça a découragé
une partie des personnes d'y aller je
pense qu'on aurait pu être président la
répuque le président de la République
pas du tout pour ça président de la
République moi je suis de ce qui pense
que sa parole et sa personne est sacré
que le président n'est pas là pour
manifester il est là pour agir et pour
faire je crois d'ailleurs que monsieur
malcal a très bien dit mieux que moi
dimanche soir sur une chaîne de
télévision il a expriqué clairement
président de la République il agit il
agit aujourd'hui par par tous les
mesures qui sont prises par l'engagement
qui est le sien contre l'an sémitisme il
n'a pas allé dans les manifestations
aujourd'hui mais là c'éit une
manifestation commun autre François
patri c'était une marche à l'appel du
président des
assemblé non à l'antisémitisme il y
avait la ministre avait estce que
c'était pas la place du chef de l'état
d'être au côté des présidents
d'assemblée de sa première ministre pour
dire non à l'antis je sais que la plus
grande partie des journalistes pensent
cette chose je sais aussi que partie de
l'opinion le pense moi je pense que et
moi d'ailleurs j'ai eu des échos chez
moi dimanche matin je suis allé à Dijon
l'après-midi à la manifestation je suis
allé avec le président du département
avec le maire de l'agglomération avec
les
parlementaires de de côor et de
Bourgogne et bien moi j'ai entendu des
gestes en me disant bah il a raison pas
y aller c'est c'est pas sa place dire
quoi ça veut dire il faut pas s'abaisser
à manifester dans la rue avec avec les
les Français qui se sont mobilisés ce
jourl non parce que vous imaginez bien
que après la polémique s'installera dès
qu'il y aura une manifestation
importante on diraah il est allé d
contre l'antisémitisme mais il vient pas
défendre aujourd'hui tel ou tel C N
manifestation d'ut manif important et si
le président est là pour aller à toutes
les manifes aussi importantes soit-elle
c'est pas son rôle c'est clair moi je
j'étais de ceux
quiésid vous considérez que c'est une
manifestation comme une autre celle de
bien entendu que non bien entendu que
non et je pense d'ailleurs qu'il aurait
pu y avoir plus de monde je pense qu'il
y avait pas beaucoup de jeunes je pense
qu'il y avit pas beaucoup de gun la
diversité je pense qu' s'il avait pas eu
ces polémiques inutiles je pense qu'il y
aurait plus de monde qu'est-ce que ça
raconte le fait qu'il y est peu de
jeunes lors de cette manifestation de
dimanche ça prouve que aujourd'hui bah
ça passe par l'instruction civique ça
passe par la prise de conscience ça fait
par le fait que la politique teruse
peut-être moins les jeunes aujourd'hui
sauf autour de l'environnement tel qui
sont et que y il y a il y a aujourd'hui
beaucoup de travail à faire pour
rappeler on est d'une génération qui n'a
pas connu les guerres ce qui est mon cas
qui n'a pas connu la Choa qui n'a pas
connu qui et qui pour elle c'est
l'histoire du passé comme comme était
pour moi la guerre de 14 voilà
Christelle une question sur les
questions d'actualité
oui
euh la présidente de l'Assemblée a
annoncé une réforme des questions
d'actualité de l'Assemblée nationale
donc qui ne seront plus de 2h le mardi
mais de mais un peu plus courte le mardi
et qui onuront aussi lieu le mercredi
juste avant les questions d'actualité du
Sénat est-ce que c'est une bonne idée
selon vous je pense que c'est pas une
bonne manière je pense que c'est pas une
bonne manière on avait réussi à se
mettre d'accord sur le temps des
questions d'actualité sont plus longues
à l'Assemblée c'est difficile à gérer 2h
je sais mais elles sont leur importance
elles sont avant celles du Sénat ce qui
fait que vous avez quand même remarqué
beaucoup de questions que nous pouvons
poser le mercredi sont déjà posées le
mardi à l'Assemblée et que le
gouvernement donc déjà nous sommes déjà
seconds ensuite mettre juste avant une
séance de questions à l'Assemblée
nationale par qu'on sait que la deuxè
heure est difficile ce qui ce qui donc
je pense c'est pas une bonne manière je
pense qu'il devrait y avoir un dialogue
je sais pas s'il a eu lieu mais je crois
que c'est Président je crois c'est
président l'archer de traiter cela avec
la président de l'Assemblée il semble
qu' vous allez vous en ouvrir à Gérard
Larché ce problème ou je pense que il y
a beaucoup de gens qui son sont émus ici
dans cette maison qui l'ont déjà dit je
pense que le président larch n'a pas
besoin que moi je m'en saisisse pour
qu'il a compris la situation non mais
vous vous êtes de la même du même groupe
que y abrun PIV est-ce que vous lui en
avez parlé non j'en ai pas parlé je l'ai
vu mais on a parlé de sujet plus
important avouer je l'ai rencontré à
deux reprises cette semaine mais on
parlait de de sujets autour des lois
autour des textes autour de la situation
et vous allez mais je v lu en parler ou
euh un mot sur les européennes Elisabeth
borne appelle Renaissance à se mobiliser
dès maintenant face au rassemblement
national est-ce que vous tardez trop à
désigner votre tête de liste et rentrer
en campagne le problème c'est pas la
tête de list c'est d'être en campagne
demain vous savez les campagnes les
campagnes et heure qui aujourd'hui euh
parmi les Français alors que les fêtes
sont pas arrivèes que les difficultés
sont là alors que les Français ont
d'autres sujets se préoccupe aujourd'hui
des européennes que les partis
politiques et c'est qui de notre de
notre appart s'en occupe et nous avons
fait nous avons une réunion cette
semaine il y a déjà eu plusieurs
réunions je crois que l'organigramme est
en place pour pouvoir à la fois surtout
préparer le programme après la liste
viendra la tête de list viendra aussi je
vois bien que d'autres certains se sont
précipités avant sont toujours en
campagne comme ils sont pas en
responsabilité ils sont en
campagne certains ministres aujourd'hui
chez vous notamment Gérald Hermin ne
s'en cache pas dit il faut y aller il
faut nommer quelqu'un parce qu'on est en
train de perdre des points et et de
prendre du retard moi je crois pas cela
je pense pas aujourd'hui qu'on perde de
points les Français sont pas fixés sur
ce sujet la campagne viendra elle sera
il faudra des combattants et des
combattants dedans parce que on voit
bien que ça se passera sur les plateaux
de télévision et pas dans la campagne
profonde tous les jours même si nous
feront tout ce que nous pouvons pour
tout le monde fera son devoir de d'aller
argumenter distribuer réunir on le fera
mais pourquoi est-ce que Renaissance
tarde autant vous avez pas trouvé le bon
candidat c'est ça le problème écoutez
moi je pense que choix du candidat de
aujourd'hui il appartient à toute la
majorité discute entre
nous j'ai pas moi alors là pas c
impatience tout le temps vous savez
j'entend toujours de la pati dans
l'impatience dans les questions qu' me
pose je me souviens que sur sur le plan
environnemental l'accélération on a dit
mais ça vient quand ça vient quand ça
vient quand c'est venu c'est pas que
nous c'estabeth qui dit faut se
mobiliser face REM elle est trop impati
elle pas dit faut le la tête de tout de
suite mais comment vous RZ en
campagne ce qui compte d'abord c'est le
programme moi je vote pour le programme
il faut pu il faut quelqu'un pour le
porter pour l'incarner bien voilà Jordan
Bardella il incarne le programme du
rassemblement national il est après de
30 % dans les Sondag Jordan ber ça à
faire ils on pas échappé que Jordan ber
n ça à faire aujourd'hui il est en
campagne permanence ils sont en campagne
il ont fait de la récupération tous les
jours ils sont devenus ils sont devenus
ils sont devenus philosémites en une
semaine un peu voilà est-ce que le
problème c'est que vous avez du mal à
choisir cette tête de liste pas du tout
mais je pense qu'il y a suffisamment de
personnes de qualité dans la majorité
pour dis don ma mais je donne vous
imaginez que je vaux pas vous donner un
nom maintenant quel soit d'abord par je
connaîi pas non mais ça je garde ça à
l'intérieur je garde ça pour les
réflexion que nous avons entre nous mais
il y a un sondage qui dit que c'est
Bruno Le Maire par exemple qui est le
mieux placé est-ce que Bruno le ma ça
serait une bonne tête de liste ou est-ce
qu'il faut que ce soit Stéphan sjourné
qui est député EUR je vois je vois au
moins 5 si ou se candidats qui sont très
bonnes tu de listes et je v pas donner
ce matin parce que il appartient à tel
ou tel écurie Bren leire je trouve que
Brena le maire est un excellent ministre
qui tient Lab tient qui tient la maison
et les finan depuis maintenant en 6 ans
il le fait avec beaucoup de
responsabilité beaucoup de loyauté
beaucoup d'engagement aujourd'hui c'est
faut savoir si d'abord il faut savoir si
les candidats ont envie d'aller à
l'Europe aujourd'hui ou est-ce qu'ils
pensent pas que leur place elle est
mieux de rester là c'est vrai de Gérald
harmanin c'est vrai de Gabriel Atal
c'est vrai d'autres aujourd'hui voyons
c'est vélisabeth
borne les premièr ministre je suis pas
sûr qu'on é voocation all est je pense
pas que ce soit je pense pas plus moi je
soutiens Elizabeth B que les choses
soient claires je pense que elle est à
son poste qu'elle est à la tâche qu'elle
est qu'elle est volontaire qu'elle anime
la majorité que on voit bien que sur le
texte immigration on a réussi à faire
beaucoup de réunions avant et qu'elle le
fait avec avec beaucoup de détermination
et de courage merci François patria
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
Christelle la Une de La Dépêche un jeu
raciste chalurau s'explique le deè ligne
de l'équipe de France qui comparaissait
hier à Toulouse en appel pour une Rix à
caractère raciste c'est à la Une de
votre
journal merci François patria au club
d'ér merci